in baseball one date when they bring in
the relief pitcher they say the starting
pitcher is responsible for the runners
I'm responsible for the runners at
Timberland and you're not a baseball fan
but by that I mean look I've been
working timber for twenty almost five
years now that's a lot of product in the
marketplace a lot of promise has made
the consumers I own those now not like
Captain queeg I don't mean this so I
said failures not successes the if if
you want to come be the CEO tomorrow
which by the way would suit the stock
market and me and my family you can come
right now and be the CEO every success
that comes from tomorrow is yours right
but every failure the trails a boot that
gets returned because it didn't work an
employee who lost their job I I own
every single one of those failures
forever they don't go away right when
when XYZ layers of 10,000 people then
next week hires 10,000 people it's not
the same 10,000 even but was the same
10,000 people you can't undo the injury
you did to somebody you can't
what's the economy the CEO cows in a
feedlot that are chewing on grass
doesn't become hamburger a derivative
product from that would be leather the
methane emissions from the cow my
accountability when someone has slips on
a piece of ice in eater in outer
Afghanistan with a pair of boots that
they bought on third hand that circuit
since timber Lana I'm not arguing legal
responsibility I'm saying to you morally
I put this thing in motion I'm the third
generation of my family to do this the
economy the CEO you own it baby it's not
sarbanes-oxley sarbanes-oxley is like a
band-aid after the fact when the
accountability I have the names in my
desk you know in the middle left-hand
drawer everybody is left Timberland the
last 18 months most of whom didn't leave
voluntarily some people lost their jobs
because I didn't do a good enough job
were in the company I keep the names
list by the way that's my problem not
theirs there's no comfort to them that
their name is on my desk I keep the list
there because I'm accountable for those
failures and I don't want to replicate
those mistakes and being a CEO you own
that period
we have all sorts of competitive
challenges Nike is a I think he's a big
hairy beast from from the west coast
along the line in my career there's been
incredible reinventions of the business
model the folks from Inditex that own
Zara from Spain have reinvented like
like único and Japan reinvented apparel
retailing one step towards fast that a
lot came desire made it really fast and
folks like H&M are doing that now so far
they haven't done that to the shoe
business per se but it used to be good
idea good shoe take your time everything
will be fine
Along Came brands like Zara who said
we're going to do that so fast your head
will spin off your shoulders so
competitive challenges I've seen
reinventions of the marketplace of real
consequence in 25 years and all I know
is it took 38 years for 50 million
people to use radio in the United States
and Facebook had 100 million users or
whatever it was in a year and so all I
learned from those statistics is
whatever we think the competitor of the
moment is we we better deploy some
people to think about tomorrow start
because the pace of danger to our
business model is higher now than it was
when we started and we can barely cope
with alone we've got and so I will call
that broad frame the business model
itself
that's not a particular competitor so
their shoes are better than ours it's
their idea of how to do business not
what to do but how to do it to me that's
an existential threat to all our
businesses surely to ours I've also made
tremendous mistakes with consumers we've
talked about that but I made the most
sort of profound failure was with was
with this consumer who wanted to be
treated with authenticity and and simple
and we made it complicated and we had a
big business and we didn't have a big
business and that's a failure that
that's mine and then I guess the one
that bothers me the most which is
neither those two although both of them
bothered me a lot is the consequence of
those kind of failures is there's loss
business their their relationships that
you set out to create and you fail to
consummate and you leave behind loss and
that's something that that's the hardest
part of what this job is